la première demi-heure ça a été ici
cette fameuse place
elle était la place de mon véhicule tout
à fait au début et après je revenais
là-bas ça a été assez
compliqué la première année c'est la
nuit la plus difficile parce que on se
dit mais on est dans les endroits où
tout le monde connaît et on a cette très
mal la réaction des gens parce que les
gens font des aveugles mais parce qu'ils
sont pas au courant la nuit ça va quand
vous êtes dans une voiture mais c'est
surtout l'un de mes réveils on a tout ce
qui a travaillé dans la tête parce qu'on
dort deux trois heures pas plus du jour
lendemain ça peut arriver à n'importe
quel on peut se retrouver dans un
problème divorce problème de travail
n'importe quoi une dépression une
dépression je ferais pas accepter d'être
dans un passage là c'était pas possible
à avoir cotisé et me retrouver là
c'était pas possible ou je loge
actuellement
dans ce fameux véhicule que vous aurez
devant vous ce véhicule est depuis un
croisant mon lieu de vie
grâce à un lycée
actuellement je me retrouve à me
débrouiller
qui est toujours plus ou moins bien
traité comme la personne oui en face
elle est moins on a le même parfum comme
ça on peut pas se perdre
alors les habits sont derrière et une
partie là vous voyez alors le matin
moi c'est pas compliqué c'est un verre
d'eau moi ce qui m'importe cette
apparence très propre ma voiture au
temple quoi parce que si vous voulez
vous relancer la bille ne fait pas le
moine mais participe première chose que
les gens vont voir c'est la tonus qui
représente quelque part il faut arriver
à travailler parce que le travail c'est
important arrivé à remettre les pieds où
il faut pas forcément au même endroit
parce qu'on peut pas faire c'est les
choses au même endroit c'est impossible
je le sais je sais que je vais être
obligé de me déplacer pour arriver à
relancer quelque chose sans que les gens
me connaissent parce que l'idée première
des gens c'est ce qu'ils ont bu
donc comment tu vas aujourd'hui
un peu de réconfort un peu de café et
puis tout simplement en association
italienne à l'aide les personnes plus
les plus vulnérables de toute façon donc
on est là aussi pour
pour le soutenir pour lui amener voilà
de l'espoir et puis de regarder vers
l'avant quoi on lui met un petit peu
d'essence à l'intérieur de la voiture ça
lui permet de se déplacer déjà solide
permet d'aller peut-être trouver un
petit travail puisqu'il est Laurent par
exemple des Carreleurs de métiers donc
s'il trouve un petit chantier s'il
trouve quelque chose mais tant mieux
pour lui le samedi dimanche il faut ça
me dégage pas du tout même si c'est pas
pour grand chose faite de travailler ça
donne la forme et ça donne envie de
continuer il faut savoir que le sang
domicile fixe ou les personnes
vulnérables ont un process et à un
moment donné il va demander il va
demander à aller lui-même dans un
appartement tout ça c'est c'est d'une
complexité énorme quand vous vivez dans
votre voiture vous faites comment pour
vous faire à manger vous faites comment
pour faire cuire votre commande pour
garder des aliments au frais vous faites
comment pour vous faire un café vous
faites comment enfin tout ce qui nous
paraît nous normal pour eux c'est
absolument impossible quoi
[Musique]